let's bring you an update on those
numbers now across the UK the total
number of deaths in the UK now standing
at 769 Katie Spencer is in the newsroom
talk us through the figures Katie yeah
well we should say the experts have
consistently said that this is what we
can expect in the coming weeks that
there will be an exponential increase in
the number of deaths that we are seeing
and before we get into the exact nuts
and bolts of these figures that have
come out this afternoon it is worth
noting that actually this week NHS
England has changed the way that it is
recording its data to make it give it
more time to effectively have more time
to collect the data itself but also to
contact the relatives of those who have
lost their lives so on Wednesday we saw
a comparatively low amount in the number
of deaths recorded because actually only
covered an eight-hour period the day
after we saw a big leap yesterday
because actually it was a much longer
period as they switch to this new system
of working which is going to be
recording the number of deaths from five
o'clock one evening to five o'clock the
next evening so we now do have these
number of deaths through this afternoon
from this new system when we're talking
about deaths as well it is worth noting
that actually we're not talking about
the number of people that have died
within that 24 hour period we're talking
about the number of recorded deaths
so actually we record the deaths when a
relative of the person that has died has
been contacted or it could be the case
that actually the person themselves died
a week ago and has been tested since
their death so it isn't as
straightforward as it would sound when
we talk about the number of deaths but
we have this afternoon found a
significant increase the total number of
deaths in the UK has risen by a hundred
and eighty five now to 769 14,000 579
people testing positive an increase of
almost 3,000 new cases of people testing
positive yesterday we were talking about
it being a significantly leap of two
thousand today we're talking about a
leap of three thousand if we break it
down into individual countries the total
number for England has now increased by
a hundred and sixty-eight deaths to 689
in Scotland it's up by
eight to thirty three deaths in total
now in Wales it's an increase of six
further deaths up to thirty four and in
Northern Ireland it is an increase of 13
as we said this is something that
actually the experts have said we should
be ready to expect we are over the
coming weeks going to see a significant
rise in the number of deaths and it is
likely to be certainly a few weeks until
we see the full effects of social
distancing come into force